we comedians are happy right but
everyone doesn't aspire to be a comedian
and you don't watch comedy all the time
even though you could laugh non-stop
more or less if the comedian's funny you
want to get your teeth into something it
also seems to me that and this is one of
the reasons I like the existential
philosophy was that you know the
existentialist believed it's sort of an
original sin idea they believe that we
came into the world with an ethical
burden already laden upon us something
like something like that and that we had
a felt sense that it was necessary for
us to justify our being and then if we
didn't do that then we weren't authentic
to ourselves we weren't moving towards
individuality
we weren't sustaining the community we
weren't living properly and that and
that that idea was deeply embedded in
people as part of their ordinary
experience and that also seems to me to
be accurate and you know I've dealt with
lots of people say in my clinical
practice and they don't really cut they
are they will come and say I wish I
wasn't so unhappy but they don't usually
come and say I wish I was happier and
those things aren't the same and and
then when when you talk to people who
are having trouble you know they want to
straighten things out and figure out how
to do them right it's something like
that and and that that's the primary
that's their primary goal and